now 5 38 on your thursday morning as
russia's invasion of ukraine continues
musicians around the world are rallying
to support the ukrainian people and that
includes a concert coming up here in las
vegas sunday afternoon at the flamingo
library near maryland parkway
[Music]
is the conductor and artistic director
of the las vegas sinfonietta i was born
in kiev ukraine and actually my father
is ukrainian and my mother is russian
sunday's concert originally scheduled
for january 23rd the birthday of genius
composer wolfgang amadeus mozart was
postponed the day before after cresa
tested positive for the coronavirus
now instead of playing mozart's last
three symphonies nobody plans for the
war at least in the music community
they'll perform his last two
adding a piece by a recently discovered
ukrainian composer they wonderfully go
together and i think it's a wonderful
treat for the listener it's a it's
a
so much fun to play and conduct and be
exposed to works of the genius whether
you can make it to the concert or not
you can donate to both the sinfuniana
and to ukrainian relief on their website
got that link on our website
eightnewsnow.com tickets for the concert
twenty eight dollars for adults fourteen
dollars for students and children
wonderful conversation with taras he's
got family and friends in both ukraine
and russia and while the ukrainians tell
him they're okay
to him that just means they've got
electricity and water but that their
lives are otherwise upside down his
moscow friends telling him how sorry
they are about everything that's
happening i've got the honor of
introducing the concert against sunday
afternoon at three at the flamingo
library does easter maryland parkway
john heather